Now that we talked about requirements prioritization, let's try to see
how this might work in practice. Imagine that you have collected the
folowing set of five requirements for an ATM system, but only
have resources to satisfy two of them. Possibly three. I would like
for you to look at this list and suitablely prioritize the
requirements by marking them as mandatory, in this case you're going to put
an M in the space. Nice to have, in this case you're
going to put an N. Or superfluous, in this case you're going to put
an S. This is the set of requirements, the first one
says that the system shall check the PIN of the ATM
card before allowing the customer to perform an operation. The second
says that the system shall perform an additional biometric verification of
the customer identity for example a check of the customer's finger
prints before it allows the customer to perform an operation. Then
we have that the system shall allow customers to withdraw cash
using an ATM card. The system shall allow customer to deposit
money using an ATM card. And the system shall allow
customers to change the pin of their ATM card. So again,
mark those as mandatory, nice to have, or superfluous considering the
fact that you can satisfy only two, possibly three of them.